i'm getting a message i don't even have
an earpiece
[Laughter]
somehow i'm getting a message
that the
contents of the same i have to say
before we come out here
that's the boxes that's what they found
today and they found a lot we're going
to talk about that but then there was a
contents of the safe no one knows what's
in the safe but we somehow this guy's
the real timer can we bring out the
content lisa oh my god this is awesome
thank you
thank you for your service
a serious guy
wow we're opening this together i've
never seen this is what was in trump's
safe don't ask me how we got this but we
did
oh my god this is so exciting uh okay oh
look at this
the pt
uh
i should have known
i should have known that that's
uh oh well this is the
dummies
uh
oh look at this what is this oh
the receipt for melania
oh trump's birth certificate up from the
republic of kenya wow that is really
shocking that that's what
uh
this
oh my god he's look at this an envelope
that says don't lose combination is safe
put in safe place
uh
oh the deed to rudy giuliani's soul
what is this
i'm like
oh it's a
[Applause]
it's a penis pump that says trump penis
on the child
oh
oh and a family photograph this must
have been precious i mean since
mom and dad january 1952.
[Applause]
you